[Music]
the royal wedding is fast approaching
and et at the intel on which of Megan
Markos family members will and won't be
there I might want to go there while
Megan and Harry's families are busy
celebrating their engagement there is
one relative who seemingly isn't on
board a source tells ET that the suit
stars half-sister samantha grant has a
chip on her shoulder adding quote she
does not have a favorable opinion of
Megan and there's definitely a lot of
animosity between them in fact the
source says samantha has penned a
tell-all about Megan and how Hollywood
has changed her oddly it was all love
when et sat down with grant last
November it's weird to be the bigger
sister and have the little sister
broaden my horizons and increase my
faith my hope my beliefs so she's
definitely done that in happier news ET
has learned that Megan asked her father
to walk her down the aisle
a move Samantha totally predicted of
course she would love her father walking
her down the aisle and I know that he'd
be proud to be there too the source also
says Megan's mother will have a
significant role on the wedding day as
for the guest list the source says Megan
will be able to invite whoever she
pleases
Samantha however will most likely be
left off the list
[Music]